[Music]
well seeing how I thought the first
scene on movie was charming enough I
expected the sequel or zzzquil haha to
at least be as good if not better as it
starts off and it seems like it's gonna
be good it has a particularly funny
opening where she sneaks into a control
room and finds what she thinks is a game
of pong not only is it funny that she's
blown away by a game like pong seeing
how it's so simple and they just don't
have games like that in the future
that's made even funnier when you find
out the paddles are actually the doors
sucking stuff into space even starting
to get people involved in there okay I
thought we were in some good hands but
sadly that's where the best stuff of the
movie stops you see another authority
figure is coming to the space station
and again is threatening to close it
down to make things worse his daughter
is the girl that she didn't get along
with in the first movie and Xenon's been
assigned to show her around and do
whatever she wants
even cut her food but Zenon can't think
too much about that is she's putting a
part of a ship to mostly just keep her
out of trouble it's a section that tries
to track any signals for alien life when
she know it as soon as Zenon takes over
she hears a signal for alien life but
for some reason nobody believes her she
said she heard the sound like a zoom
zoom and what they don't have a
recording of it they can't go back they
can't hear it again this is the
technologically advanced future
naturally this happens a couple times
and every single time she's the only one
in the room and she has to tell
everybody it happened again with nobody
believing her so she once again travels
back to earth again spending the
majority of the film down there
reuniting with her and her best friend
and of course the girl she doesn't like
who sneaks off with her for some reason
and they tried to find the rock star
from the end of the first film because
they think that the message is actually
his song and the aliens want to talk to
him oh do you find this ridiculous yet
don't get me wrong
the firs enon was a silly film but it
had a little bit of a charm and
creativity to it this is just on repeat
except there's little charming about it
most of the characters aren't even that
likable I hate how nobody believes her I
hate this girl that's supposed to be
annoying but instead of coming off as
funny annoying she's just annoying
annoying I hate the fact that she breaks
up with the
a friend at the beginning of the film
and is treated like no big deal no
actually it is a big deal it kind of
affects her but not enough to pay him to
have him come back in the movie the
musician gets annoying the ant gets
annoying the parents get annoying the
general is annoying everything just has
a slow unimaginative feel to it even the
aliens at the end when you finally see
them just kind of look like rejects from
the abyss at times it's even hard to
follow there's a lot of talk about what
the aliens want and how they want them
and let me tell you I watch a lot of
Star Trek and even I couldn't follow
this how the hell are kids supposed to
comprehend it even the layout of the
scenes don't even make sense like the
aliens finally come and everybody sees
them and they're like oh my god life on
a different planet and then Zenon still
being punished and she's trying to tell
him what's going on and they're like
where's your proof what do you mean
where's your proof the aliens were just
there how can you still not believe her
but then they do it again yeah the
aliens just come by and flash things and
didn't we just see this why was there
that little scene of her getting balled
out Oh what is this oh the annoying girl
can finally stand up for her you could
have had that an earlier scene and truth
be told she's so unlikable I'm still not
quite on her side when she sneaks off
with Xena and she leaves a letter to her
father saying that she's been kidnapped
freaking kidnapped what's wrong with
these people
okay okay so is this a terrible film
I guess not it's just your
run-of-the-mill bad the characters are
all morons a lot of the moments seem
recycled the effects are a little better
I'll give it that but aside from that
there's really not much to it it's fine
because this is the kind of film I
assume the first Xenon would be like you
know kinda lame has aliens and some dumb
technology that makes no sense and lame
lines but the first one kind of
surprised me and I thought it was an
okay kids film because of that else
actually expecting more out of this one
and instead I got what I suppose I
should have been expecting like I said
I'm not gonna act like it's the worst
thing ever but I definitely wouldn't
take this trip to the stars anytime soon
[Music]
you